la estadificación del cáncer cervical se
refiere a la extensión de la enfermedad
los médicos especifican la enfermedad
según el tamaño del tumor y si se ha
extendido a tejidos cercanos u otros
órganos del cuerpo el estadio 0 no se
considera invasivo porque las células
cancerígenas se encuentran solo en la
capa superficial de las células del
cuello uterino el estadio 1a se
considera cáncer invasivo porque el
tumor microscópico crece a través de la
capa superficial de las células hasta el
tejido cervical subyacente y tiene de 3
a 5 milímetros de profundidad por 7
milímetros de ancho el cáncer cervical
de estadio 1 v presenta dos escenarios
uno donde el tumor aún puede verse solo
con un microscopio pero mide más de
cinco milímetros de profundidad y siete
milímetros de ancho en el segundo
escenario para el estadio uno ve el
cáncer puede verse sin un microscopio y
tiene más de cuatro centímetros de
diámetro en el estadio 2a el tumor se
extiende más allá del cuello uterino
hasta los dos tercios
de la vagina pero no llega a los tejidos
que rodean el útero en el estadio 2 ve
el cáncer se extiende a los tejidos que
rodean el útero en el estadio 3a el
tumor se extiende al tercio inferior de
la vagina
en el estadio 3 ve el cáncer se extiende
a la pared pélvica el revestimiento de
la cavidad de la pared abdominal entre
las caderas o puede extenderse a los
uréteres tubos que llevan la orina desde
los riñones hasta la vejiga si el flujo
de orina se bloquea los riñones pueden
agrandarse o dejar de funcionar en el
estadio 4a
el tumor invade órganos pélvicos
cercanos como la vejiga o el recto y
puede extenderse a los ganglios
linfáticos de la pelvis en el estadio 4
ve el cáncer se extiende más allá de los
ganglios linfáticos de la pelvis a otros
lugares del cuerpo como el hígado los
intestinos o los pulmones